I hope there's a heaven man yeah that'd
be awesome
but here's why I don't think here's
where I think maybe there's not a heaven
because I haven't supposed to be [ __ ]
perfect right you're the afterlife and
you're supposed to [ __ ] live your
[ __ ] and have the best time ever and all
the rules are [ __ ] beautiful and you
get whatever you want because you were a
good guy in the [ __ ] trial life okay
but say I've fallen say I've fall in
love with a girl sad love her so [ __ ]
much and then say she breaks my heart
and then say she gets married again and
then she falls in love with her [ __ ]
new guy and saved the rest of my life I
[ __ ] think about her every day and I
wish she was with me and I'm a good
purse and I [ __ ] do everything I do
for other people not to get points with
God but because I want to be a good
person anyway and malicious and say she
is too and she falls in love with
another man and loves his [ __ ] out that
guy and she's good purse and she doesn't
want to [ __ ] do things to get points
with God she wants to do things because
she's a good person and then say I die
and I go to heaven what do I want I want
to be with her and then say she dies and
she goes to heaven and what does she
want she wants to be with that guy still
so min hell cuz I can't be with her it's
how the [ __ ] is there a heaven if
everybody's heaven is different then
what then [ __ ] what I'm in heaven
she's not there or she is there or a
version of her is there but then it's
not the real her then we're getting into
some [ __ ] Blackmer [ __ ] I want the
real her I'm just saying it's something
to think about dude I'm sure there's
some [ __ ] buttoned up [ __ ]
that can tell me what the hell is going
on however I don't know man what if my
[ __ ] dog do all do dogs gonna heaven
dude and if they do what my dog hates me
what my doors like dude I can't wait to
get out this [ __ ] house I hate this
[ __ ] guy all he does is like to hold
me and [ __ ]
dog gets to heaven goes to doggy heaven
or you see a [ __ ] do I still get to
own him
come on man it doesn't want to be owned
you know how I know I left the door open
once my dog took a [ __ ] vacation man
until somebody picked him up and called
me yeah dude uh so I don't know I I
trailed off here there was some I wanted
to talk about but I don't remember I
don't remember I always I mean Mormons
were [ __ ] underwear you know they
were [ __ ] holy underwear I would love
for them to die and go to heaven no I
wouldn't want them to die but I love for
them when they die go to heaven and be
like hey we did everything and God was
like why should we that stupid [ __ ]
underwear that'd be hilarious
look oh we thought that's what you
wanted Oh oh it doesn't matter when we
we still made us good people huh God God
let God rolls his eyes that's my god God
rolls his [ __ ] eyes that's what I
want when I get to if I if there is one
and I get there I want my god to be like
how about these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
on earth I don't laugh and we'll both
laugh and [ __ ] man you know we don't
think enough what heaven would be like I
think we're just like oh yeah it'll be
great it'll be great we don't think
about what the [ __ ] the logistics of it
would be you know Tupac's my favorite is
he there
Tupac probably wouldn't even [ __ ]
like me he'd be like get this
[ __ ] out of my sight yeah then
I'd be like but Jesus I love Tupac and
then Jesus would be like he doesn't look
he thinks you're not funny
he thinks you're lanky and he said that
you he doesn't like your beard
and I'd be like what what the [ __ ]
that have to do with anything is not who
I am and he was like he just didn't get
along he doesn't like you he he said he
doesn't like your your type of person
you don't like your type of people not
like well he's racist
no it's not a racist thing you said you
didn't like like guys who you think you
laugh at your jokes too much well
[ __ ] this is hell and he's like is it
really though you got all the [ __ ]
turkey you want and you can get [ __ ]
whenever you want I'm like I guess yeah
I mean but just weird though it's not
really heaven you know it's just kind of
like another kind of I kind of got as
many [ __ ] as I wanted in my life and
I could just go to the store to eat
turkey and he'd be like yeah well what
did you [ __ ] want I mean there's too
many people out there you can still
listen to Tupac's music I'm like yeah I
guess I'd be like this is just like
Earth you know what the [ __ ] and then
Jesus would be like well it's [ __ ]
hard up here beyond these clouds I'm
trying to make everybody happy you know
and I a I didn't you know I didn't think
Tupac wasn't gonna like I wasn't sure
and now I got an o2 Park doesn't like
because he's dead and I'm dead too and
we're in that's worse I was imagine
Tupac and I might get along and then
Jesus is like you know [ __ ] look
Napoleon was a good guy yeah he tried to
conquer the world but like in his heart
of hearts even though that means nothing
he was a good guy even though people say
heart of hearts and that means nothing
Napoleon was a good guy he helped a lot
of people and he's here and he's trying
to take over a lot of heaven and I don't
know how to fix it I got him some women
and he has sex with a lot of women and
it's actually pretty shitty because I
feel like I'm sexist but at least he's
not conquering the parts of heaven that
I love because he's getting sucked off a
lot and honestly he gets along with
Tupac and I gotta be like [ __ ]
Napoleon gets along with Tupac he he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] man alright whatever I
guess at least can I have sex with Emily
right at chetowski and he's like he's
like listen that's she happens to think
you look like a bird and I'm like my
mother [ __ ] dude that's that's heaven
that's heaven you can't have your
[ __ ] oh you can't unless you're gonna
have your own heaven
alright now okay
oh I can't have sex with Emily right it
to chow ski I did it cuz she doesn't
want to have sex with me in heaven just
like in [ __ ] earth probably [ __ ] and
then he's like listen there's some other
bad news I got I'm like what there's
like logan paul and jake paul just got
into a car accident and they're here and
I'm like you're kidding me what the [ __ ]
and he's like well you've been dead for
quite some time and yeah he filmed of
hanging corpse and that was bad and I
thought he was gonna actually go to hell
but since then he's only done good and
repented and I'm like oh no and he's
like so he's here and then faintly in
the background I hear what's up heaven
tube and I'm like there's heaven tube
and then he's like and then he's like
for [ __ ] and then he's like well he
that's what he wanted and I'm like but I
don't want that heaven is just like
earth or it's not
or it's not and you just die and you
sleep forever